metro police say the suspect involved in  monday's officer-involved shooting  downtown used a pen as a weapon officers  tell us 26-year-old hector orianna was  fighting with another man near las vegas  boulevard and owens lieutenant raul  rodriguez who was in an unmarked car  stopped to intervene orianna reportedly  charged him with a pen in his hand  lieutenant rodriguez then fired three  rounds shot orellano not knowing what he  was holding  he describes it as a screwdriver and  then another point he says a metal  object  one of the witnesses described it as a  shank  and so  it was really hard to tell  what it was  now the other man involved in that fight  or ran off orianna was taken to the  hospital is now ok we're told he is  facing multiple charges including  assault with a deadly weapon on a  protective person